free throws that he's been shooting all
game long
he has been magnificent at the line
[Music]
50 points
only the seventh player in the history
of the finals to have a 50-point game
elgin baylor rick barry michael jordan
jerry west lebron james bob pettit
and giannis athena kupo
[Applause]
a rare miss tonight
and the suns will call their final
timeout down seven with 8.9 remaining
the players exhausted will go to their
benches
[Applause]
the milwaukee bucks
on the verge
8.9 seconds remain
and what has been another thrilling game
between these two teams
[Music]
finals featuring two teams that had not
been here in decades of finals without
the familiar star power that we've had
in recent years
but that's what i call star power
and the huge smile
[Applause]
they put the clock back to 9.5 seconds
[Applause]
50 points 14 rebounds five blocked shots
50 of 105 points nearly half the team's
total
now jeff with 9.5 remaining
a miracle finish would have to obviously
happen for finish to pull it out and
again they're out of time outs
that's why you've got to concentrate on
the details
[Music]
[Applause]
booker turns shoots fires shot won't go
chuckle the rebound
and that'll do it
it's over
the bucks have done it the long wait has
ended after a half century the milwaukee
bucks are nba champions once again
the emotions come pouring out
one of the greatest nights in milwaukee
sports history ends in a coronation
and the brilliance
of the young man from athens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
another crushing finish for devin booker
and the phoenix suns
after a superb season
this extraordinary story
of this extraordinary young man
gives him his nba title
the greek freak
is a greek nba champion
[Applause]
guys we've seen a lot of amazing
performances
this ranks is one of the all-time
greatest it absolutely does we've
witnessed lebron james for so long
but we've seen a guy put up lebron james
type numbers
especially after the fact that he was
supposed to be out the rest of the way
after that scary injury
and then the defensive
component and effort and example
that he set
he was
sprinting and
blocking and
running the floor and the only guy who
had it going offensively
the burden was great
and he was up to the task
b.j tucker acquired mid-season
a big part of the success of this team
in the playoffs
he has such a sense of loyalty his
family first
but to the bucks in the city of
milwaukee he's talked about everyone has
a different path to a title i'm not
judging anyone but for me
i want to do it with the team that took
a chance on me a city that welcomed me
and with teammates that i went through
the highs and lows with i feel like it
just means more
these two teammates
long years together are nba champions
together
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is going to be some wild night in
downtown milwaukee
the last time the bucks won a
championship 1971.
again they're saying that's 65 000.
he wanted to do it
in the city that he now calls home
mission accomplished brianna
sapirpo this is always the fun part guys
the celebrations these phenomenal
grown men behave with the exuberance of
children
just so happy
after the years of sacrifice the years
of hard work the years of pain
and the emotions come pouring out
[Applause]
right now
when you resigned your contract your
extension
i'm sure it was with this in mind
could you imagine it happening for you
the way that it happened
no no no
man i i just
i just i
i couldn't live
you know there was there was there was a
job that had to be finished you know i
feel like the bible did not pay that
first paid us justice you know
give credit to miami he played great but
he did not pay the justice like
everybody was feeling homesick we family
oriented team wanted to see our families
and and uh
but you know coming back i was like
this is my city you know they
trust me they believe in me they believe
in us even when we were like we were
lost the city still was like on our side
and um
you know obviously i want i wanted to
get the job done
you know uh
but that's my stubborn side like it's
easy to go somewhere and
go and win a championship with somebody
else it's easy i could go like i don't
put anybody in the spot but i could go
to a super team
and you know just do my part and win a
championship still but this is the hard
way to do it and this is the way i chose
to do it
and we did it
[ __ ] did it
we did it man
jim on the front right
it all starts with the switching of
lopez
it puts too much pressure on your
defense paul deflects it crowded and
bridges bridges up inside blocked by
antenna
what a recovery when the bucks come the
other way holiday spins layup shot will
go and lopez is fouled
for a guy with a hyper extended knee
what a fantastic defensive play
this is reminiscent of lebron james
in cleveland against golden state what
an effort
[Applause]
incredible block
he only knows one way to play
just perfect timing
[Applause]
get too complicated
[Applause]
now booker with tucker on him throws it
up for ayton shot blocked by antenna
what a block from giannis
he looks up drives throws it up
no good rebound [ __ ]
sons have a timeout
decide not to call it
[ __ ] the drive gets inside leans in
knocked away and stolen by holiday
phoenix has to foul
throws it down
gets into the pitcher comes up with the
strip
turning the basketball over and then off
to the races
could have held it out instead made the
right read throws it up where only
giannis can catch it
finishes it with the contact and bad
decision to foul because this would make
it
a four-point game with 13.5 remaining
phoenix still has a timeout rebound
crowder
oh money williams says mikhail bridges
running the floor shot blocked by
antenna
once again comes out of nowhere and
throws it off the backboard janus down
the other end he takes it home
just a tremendous in transition chase
down play
holliday finds some room kicks it out
connoisseur
middleton inside nice century pass and
the slam from the tunnel
on the offensive end catch finishing
traffic
over everybody